They're going to record it over there. I mean,
I'm going to record it here to you. Three, two, one. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab and today evil, although, no,
I don't know if that's the right word for this next thing. Yeah.
Cause it's sort of more complicate when you call someone evil,
then you're kind of done with them. But there's been a fellow,
I've been thinking about him from bitter part of the year as you know,
such a puzzle to me. I can't quite please him though.
It's very fun to try. And I heard about him from science writers, Sam Keen.
Well let's talk about Fritz Haber. So, so first of all, could you just like,
when did he live and what did he look like and that kind of stuff?
Uh, he was doing his,
his great science work right around the turn of the 20th century.
So right around 1900 very distinctive looking man bald on top trim.
Nice mustache. Wore a little, um, uh, peas Nez. Is that how you say the,
is that the for notice princess? Okay. One of those very tiny old fashioned,
uh, pair of glasses that would pinch on your nose.
And he was someone who had very big ambitions.
Just to put that in context, uh, I'd bring a few other of our storytellers in.
He comes from Breslau, Germany, that's Fred Kaufman reporter, which is a,
a fairly small, you know, smaller sort of town. And uh, so does Clara.
That's for topper's wife. We're gonna meet her later. Right?
Clara comes from the same town and they're both secularized Jews.
But this was a moment in German history.
He says when Jews had a decent amount of freedom,
and this is the difference between Kaiser Wilhelm and of course Hitler's
Germany. Yeah. Put it in context. Dan Charles, he's a historian.
His was the first generation when a young Jewish boy could truly imagine that he
could just be a regular part of that society. He could do anything.
And he believed it. Fast forward 10 years for topper as a professor,
small university is working with chemicals. It's about 1880.
And he throws himself at one of the central issues facing Germany that at that
time Germany has a problem, a big problem.
It has enough what they used to call then solar energy, you know,
energy from the sun to grow crops to feed about 30 million people.
However that leaves behind 20 million Germans.
Do you mean they're looking at 20 million people going hungry?
That's what we're heading towards. I mean you have to remember it during the,
during the Crimean war in the 1850s Europe starves,
so around the turn of the century for German scientists like hopper,
this was the challenge. He is, he wants to feed,
he wants to feed Germany and actually this wasn't just a German thing.
A lot of people were beginning to worry that with about a billion and a half
people on the planet at that point that maybe we were maxing out that the earth
couldn't support this many people and everyone thought, well,
we know the solution. Yeah, we just need a whole lot more of one simple element.
Nitrogen, nitrogen, nitrogen, nitrogen, they needed more nitrogen.
Nitrogen is an essential part of amino acids and proteins.
And when you stick a seed like a weed seed in the ground,
one of the reasons it grows is because it's sucking up all the nitrogen in the
soil to make it cell walls. Without nitrogen,
you don't have life
[inaudible].
Now of course you could find it some nitrogen out in the world.
Natural deposits would be like seaweed or manure was one, you know,
you could find it in cow manure or one no,
which was basically bat poop and seagull poop, which made that poop valuable.
And actually two nations in South America went to war.
Literally over bet. You could say people work best. Crazy. By the way,
that's reporter lot tiff Nasir, you know, this was like oil is today. This is,
everybody was desperate for sources, new sources of nitrogen.
And to make the problem even more annoying,
the most common source of nitrogen is in the air around us.
[inaudible]
ah,
it makes up four out of every five or so molecules that we breathe.
So it's very a lot. Yes,
80% of the air is nitrogen atoms. So all the
could you ever need what's right there.
You can't like throw that air onto a plant, you know, they couldn't deploy it.
They couldn't deploy it, meaning they couldn't capture it. That's right.
And part of the problem here,
and although once again we're getting a little ahead of ourselves,
we'll be right back to high, but wait, wait,
let's just finish this is that is that nitrogen is try Vaillant try,
try Vaillant. In other words,
nitrogen has really strong attachments to itself.
And what he means is that when nitrogen atoms are just free floating in the air,
they will cling to each other.
These little nitrogen atoms will fiercely hold together and it's almost
impossible to pry them apart. His calculation showed that it couldn't be done,
at least not without a tremendous amount of energy.
More energy than seem like possible to make. Yeah. Yes. But you know,
being ambitious harbor starts thinking,
in order to do this we need to Ah, pressure this.
We need to put it under a lot of pressure. So he starts experimenting.
He figures out a way to take a lot of air that's filled with these little
nitrogen bonds clinging to each other and [inaudible] pump it with big iron
[inaudible] under extreme extreme pressure at high temperature.
And then he forces hydrogen into the tech get in there and you have a number of
chemical reactions
and what happens is that you're, you're elbowing the month,
the nitrogen apart from excel and then forcing it to on [inaudible] with the
hydrogen in a new way. And when hydrogen and nitrogen bond together,
the thing you get is ammonia,
a liquid that has captured the nitrogen right out of the air.
You literally get a drip, drip,
drip of ammonia.
Ah,
it is, it is arguably
the most significant scientific breakthrough of the mall.
Bread from the air was the phrase cause hopper had figured out a way to take
nitrogen from the air,
put it into the barren ground and grew wheat.
This has allowed the world to have 7 billion people.
This is what's driving the world towards 10 12 by 2050
[inaudible]
now we're seeing about a hundred million tons of synthetic fertilizer produced
industrially each year.
And the tonnages then moves into our food source.
Our food source then moves into our bodies.
And the rough statistics are that half of each of our bodies contains nitrogen
from the harbor process, knows really
[inaudible].
And so in 1918 fritz hopper gets a Nobel prize, but this is my,
this is such an interesting guy. Around the same time,
officials in the u s government are calling him a war criminal.
All right. Just to back up for one second, after harbor's nitrogen discovery,
he was promoted. You know,
he takes over the leadership of this institute in Berlin and he starts
hobnobbing with a whole different level of society that Stan Charles Again,
I mean, it's a pretty heady thing for, you know,
a Jewish kid from Breslau to be hobnobbing with the emperor and cabinet
ministers. He's part of the club and he really, really relished it.
And not just cause he was vain, which everyone agrees he was,
but because he loves his country. He loves the father land and he loves Germany.
So when World War One begins,
he signs up immediately sends a letter volunteering for duty saying,
you know the process that I use to make food.
Well I can use that same process to make explosives
because the thing that you put into the ground to grow more food is also the
thing you can explode to make a bomb.
That's correct because it takes such energy and pressure to separate it.
This try Vaillant bond is so strong that when it comes back together
at energy that's released,
it can be used for life or death.
In any case, back to World War One, there's trench warfare,
it gets bogged down and harbor has an idea.
It goes straight to the German high command and he and he pitches this idea.
He says, well,
we can drive those enemy soldiers out of trenches with gas.
Chlorine gas will basically bring it to the front and when the,
when the wind is right, we'll just spray it.
But the generals were not all that convinced now. They just didn't like it.
A lot of them were like, this is not how you fight a war.
It's like playing dirty. Yeah,
sort of unsportsmanlike but he organizes soldiers.
He organizes whole gas units and nobody even had to ask takes command of them.
Partially he travels to the front and on April 22nd yeah,
1950 1915 Hubbard finds himself in a little town in Belgium called e y.
P. R. E. S actually the Americans called it Yips, whatever you call it.
This was one of the bloodiest arenas on the western front.
The Germans were on one side, the fringe,
the Canadians and the British on the other,
and they're behind the German lines is our, our, our friend, our friend of mine,
uh, for a topic, a friend of, he's bald, he has a pot belly.
He has these pos. Nez spectacles is chomping on a Virginian cigar.
He was always smoking these Virginian cigars and he's wearing a fur coat really?
And what is basically like the Baghdad of his time, but nobody
had done what he was about to do on the scale that he was about to do it.
So basically at 6:00 PM on April 22nd when the wind was just right,
he says harbors gas troops on unscrew, they opened the valve
on almost 6,000 tanks containing 150 tons of chlorine.
That's like an adult blue whale of chlorine. Just trying to imagine that.
Is that like a, like a green cloud?
Some people describe it as a cloud and then others describe it as this kind of
15 foot wall kind of hugging the land and it's just sort of approach and it's
moving at about one meter per second and according to some accounts as it crept
across no man's land,
the leaves would just sort of shrivel and the grass was turning to the color of
metal.
Birds would just fall from the air within minutes the gas reached the allied
side and as soon as it did,
soldiers began to convulse. They were gagging, they were choking,
hundreds of them were falling to the ground. What is the guest doing to them?
Exactly. I think what it's doing is it's a, if you breathe it in,
it sort of irritates your lungs to the extent that they sort of filled up with
fluid so quickly that you sort of drown in your own Flamm.
So they weren't actually drowning, literally drowning on land. Wow.
Yellow Mucus was throbbing out of their mouth.
Those who could still breathe would turn blue.
This is the description of hell. Yeah.
But harbor solid has a wonderful success and wished,
wished that the Germans had been better prepared to exploit it because he felt
like they really could have made a terrific advance if they had had more
confidence
and he is celebrated for it.
He gets promoted to the rank of captain and he goes home for a few days a hero.
But when he gets there, he has to contend with his wife, Clara Emma Var.
Clara also from Breslau off also from a Jewish family and also a scientist. Huh.
Unusually so in those times she was actually a sort of a genius herself.
She was one of the first women to earn a Ph d in her country.
And shortly after his return, Clara allegedly confronts him and says, look,
you are morally bankrupt. How could you? Um,
but Haber just kind of ignored her. And according to legend,
he actually threw a dinner party in celebration of the big victory,
invited his friends over. Now we don't actually know if he threw a party.
Like I consider that apocryphal. Dan doesn't think so.
But what's clear is that he saw no reason to question what he had done.
And that infuriated Clara especially because she found out he was leaving the
next day to direct more gas attacks. And they probably had an argument. Yeah.
And that was it. They had an argument. That's historian Fritz Stern,
who also happens to be fritz Hopper's Godson. They had a quarrel more than that,
let's call it a fight.
And later that night after the party harbor takes a bunch of sleeping pills,
goes to sleep. Um,
and she takes the service revolver,
Ventavis pistol walks outside to the garden and
[inaudible]
pulls the trigger,
shoots herself in the chest and is found by her son,
by her son. Yes. Age to 18, I think. Uh,
and he finds her actually still alive with the life about to run out of her, uh,
harbor. It's unknown what happens for the rest of that evening,
but it is a well-documented fact that the very next morning on schedule,
he goes back to the, to the front, to the eastern front, leaving
his son, uh,
alone with his dead mother.
Oh, cold, Huh? Yeah. Heartless ed was a terrible moment.
Did he run away? Was it duty?
The sign eventually after he emigrates to America
kills himself.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
see now around this point,
I just don't want to have anything to do with this guy. This is a,
I just want to take a shower. Walk away. Yeah.
Yeah, me too.
You know, on the other hand, I mean,
if you look at the grand calculus people he's had helped or fed versus people
he's killed. I mean, he's felt that billions of people.
I don't know that you could entirely call him bad.
I might even tilt towards saying he's a little good to be honest.
You wouldn't though, would you really?
Would you really think that this guy's a good guy? Honestly, yeah. You know,
just because of a mathematical summing up, we're talking billions of people.
He's standing there on the front pushing the gas into the lungs or other human
beings. It's merely, it's a war, but still. Then he goes and you know,
and celebrates that and then walks away from his child and his wife did in the
garden and says more of that, please. Well,
there's something distasteful about the fact that he was too into it,
but like I do think on some level you have to divorce the man from his deeds and
you've got to ask, is the world better with him or without him?
I think you've got to answer it with him. Right.
Well, should we keep going with the story? Yeah. Alright.
So Sam, what happened to this guy after World War One?
He actually was very humiliated that Germany had lost and especially humiliated
over the fact that they had to pay enormous war reparations to other countries.
So he decided he was going to invent a process to pay for these reparations by
himself. And what he decided to do is go into the ocean,
into sea water, which contains, um, uh,
very small levels of gold. But you know,
over the entire ocean there's a lot of gold dissolved into the sea and he spends
five years and a few tile effort to distill gold from the ocean's waters.
Sounds insane. On the other hand, if anyone could do it,
he was trying to repeat this master stroke. Needless to say, he fails.
It was actually a crushing blow for him, for him.
And then things really take a turn.
1933 comes and Hitler takes over.
And one of the first acts that the Nazis do is to basically issue in order that
says there shall be no Jews in the civil service. Now harbor was Jewish,
but because he'd served in World War One, he technically would be exempt,
but 75% of the people who worked for him at the institute,
they were Jewish and they would have to be dismissed.
So he decides to take a stand and says, this is intolerable.
I'm going to resign. He says that he's a,
he's always been hiring people based on how smart they are and not who their
grandparents were. So he sends a letter to the Ministry of Education, resigning,
and he leaves Germany telling a friend. He felt like he'd lost his homeland.
And then he starts this period of roaming.
He eventually goes to England. But in a famous incident,
one of England's leading scientists refuses to shake his hand.
And he is basically homeless at this point. You know,
he's a man adrift. Meanwhile, his health is failing.
In 1934 he takes a trip to Switzerland to a sanatorium,
but before he can get there, his heart fails and he dies.
Mm.
Now there's a footnote to this that is very strange.
Um, I got a little, uh,
less as my dorsal heres stood up when I read the end of this. Right.
So during World War One harbors institute had a formulation
of, um,
insect killing gas called Zyklon Zyklon a,
which was originally just a pesticide. And once again,
another nitrogen compound, it was developed in his institute. He knew about it.
In fact, his chemist had given this particular pesticide a smell. It was a,
it was a warning smell so that people didn't inadvertently breathe it in and get
sick. But after the Nazis take over, this is after he died,
they reached back to the shelf and they find this Zyklon stuff and they asked
for it to be reformulated to take out the warning smell and it becomes Zyklon B,
the killing gas of the concentration camps.
[inaudible]
did members of Hubbard's family die in the concentration camps? Yeah.
Members of his extended family did.
Certainly friends of his dead is something deeply,
deeply wounding, stressing,
upsetting at the thought that he had anything to do with sibling and B,
but he did the use of it. He could never match.
[inaudible]
so how do you feel about him now? Because I don't know.
I can't help it feel bad for the guy despite the chlorine gas.
Like he didn't intend for that to happen. He could have never imagined that. No.
What? But, but there's part of me that says, you know,
here's a guy who just wanted to do everything better than he had ever been done
before, whether it was feeding or killing. And he does, and he does,
but he does it with a kind of immoral athleticism. You know, he,
he does it without humility, without, without a lot of doubt. And you know,
it's a craft,
but it's a craft with consequences and to approach it with kind of crazy joy.
I don't know.
I would rather have scientists who carry doubt with them as they proceed.
Yeah, I agree with that. Maybe it's all about doubting.